if everyone in your entire high school
suddenly turned into flesh-eating
zombies what would you do the world as
you know it has been infected by a
deadly virus and nowhere is safe i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
undead zombies in high school of the
dead all these hopeful kids with bright
futures are about to die takashi here is
your everyday high school student who is
sulking the day away by getting some
peace and quiet little does he know that
his reality is about to change for the
worse he soaks around some more and
while leaning off the school balcony
suddenly sees something super strange at
the school gates it's a person but
something is not right and they're
acting strange takashi then spots some
school teachers confronting the strange
man at the gate when all of a sudden
this strange man tears the teacher's
flesh right in front of him the bitten
man screams and collapses and the other
teachers stare in shock then all of a
sudden he sees the bitten teacher get
back up and bite another one of the
teachers takashi's eyes bulge as he runs
off knowing what we know that everyone
here is about to turn into flesh eating
zombies well i certainly hope that
takashi is a fan of the movies because
if this goes anything like a normal
zombie movie or tv show then takashi
would be questioning what he saw for
half the film and wouldn't have used the
word zombie until the very end of the
show if ever just like some other zombie
tv shows that i won't mention but the
fact of the matter is is that the
concept of the undead since its
resurgence from its possible ancient
greek origin has been around since
zombie lover george a romero popularized
it in the 1968 film knight of the living
dead and since then there has been at
least 7 900 films not including tv shows
meaning that at this point in time
knowing the traits habits and weaknesses
of a zombie is too ingrained in our pop
culture to not know a zombie when you
see one and since we know that what
we're seeing is a zombie i wouldn't
hesitate to stop the outbreak before
telling anyone else you're welcome now
from the looks of things that zombie by
the gate was slow thank god because
we're no brad pitt we're better which
means that we could have had enough time
to run downstairs to the kitchen
cafeteria grab a chair and a knife
before pulling up at the gate to kill
the one or two freshly baked out of the
oven zombies before they had the chance
to spread the infection even further in
the school if takashi knows what's good
for him he should put a stop to this
before [ __ ] hits the fan and preparing
for the incoming zombie pandemic before
[ __ ] hits the fan is the exact reason
why you'll love state of survival our
sponsor for today's video state of
survival is a zombie themed survival
strategy mobile game that is both
available on apple and google app stores
a game that begins with a firm financial
foundation known as gigacorp which just
finishes building a deadly weapon
releasing chaos across the world and you
as a survivor expected to rebuild your
last home as well as fight off countless
zombies and finding the man responsible
for all this the man known as klein
beginning on 25th november through
january will be when this limited time
crossover event begins starring a hero
or should we say anti-hero the joker
himself and this includes customized
weapons and skills as well as a
customized storyline unique to the joker
himself with fun themed gameplay and
in-game events such as the arena of doom
where players will compete against
laughing zombies a new type of zombie as
well as other players having you saving
folks building defenses and fighting off
zombies left and right liking the
explorer trail which will have you
explore unknown areas whilst fighting
off waves of different zombies with
multiple game modes available from pvp
pve as well as kvk so download state of
survival now using the link below to
experience this limited time crossover
event and use my creator code httpsos to
redeem an in-game starter pack
containing 300 biocaps one epic search
map 50 000 food water metal 1 000 cheap
exp and the rare hero rusty himself but
the number of starter packs is limited
to first come first serve as well as 10
50 amazon gift cards for new players so
download my link and reach level 6.
thank you to state of survival for
sponsoring this video and now back to
the show takashi then buzzed into the
classroom and grabs a hold of his
childhood friend rey saying that people
are being killed outside and that they
need to get out of here this grabs the
attention of takashi's friends nearby
including his best friend hisashi the
gang runs out of the classroom and just
then they hear on the pa intercom that
the school is in a state of emergency
and that violence has erupted in the
school panic and utter chaos takes over
after every single student hears the
terrifying screams of the dying teacher
on the intercom hisashi says that they
should head to the roof and wait for
help and so they set off encountering a
scary zombie on the way there and
realizing that they're more dangerous
than they look barely escaping with
their lives but not before one of them
loses their only chance at survival
hisashi has been bitten and i suppose
you can say he can thank his lucky stars
because they don't know that certain
death awaits him elsewhere we see
countless groups of people getting
killed left and right even best friends
backstabbing each other to survive
showcasing to us the ultimate savagery
that mankind is capable of reaching the
roof the gang sees all around them that
the whole of the area and maybe even the
world has gone into complete chaos just
as more zombies start to surround them
forcing them to run past the hordes and
barricade themselves up past this
staircase but hisashi is now on the
brink of death and asks takashi to kill
him as they both know what will soon
happen to him all of a sudden hisashi
turns into a flesh-eating zombie forcing
takashi to sack up and end his best
friend's life well that's not fair i
just lost the one person who i know
would be a guarantee to like my next
instagram pic but takashi what are you
doing you should have ended your
friend's life before he turned coming
courtesy hello i would have also begun
taking notice of the victims in the
school when we were in the clear because
the one thing that zombie pop culture
doesn't guarantee is the incubation
period of a zombie bite before someone
turns and this is something that we
should work on finding out asap because
the first bite mark victims at the
school gate turned almost instantly
whereas my best friend took his sweet
ass time to die if i was takashi aside
from making sure that we begin looking
for weapons i'd also begin taking notes
on the zombie enemy i would have also
used this time to examine my friend's
dead body i would begin looking around
his bite mark to see if there were any
tell-tale signs of rapid infection or
warning signs laden on the surface of
his skin from any rashes to hives to
skin disorders beginning to form around
his body or around the bite mark because
we know that this virus on a molecular
level changes the physical appearance of
a zombie victim so we might as well
study the signs of someone who has been
bitten because the next person who we
befriend who ends up getting bitten
might not be as honest with us as our
best friend was elsewhere the horrifying
carnage continues while this pink-haired
girl and glasses guy have decided to
pair off and run as fast as they can
with glasses guys saying that they
should head to the teacher's lounge for
help but pink-haired girl points out
that another group had the same dumb
idea across the top floor back on the
school roof rey tries calling her dad
who is a cop but can't get through to
him showing that not even the adults
teachers or even cops can save them now
or dare i say even the military at the
medical bay blonde hair girl here is
trying to grab the remaining medicine
bottles but she's too slow and zombies
break through the door they savagely
tear her friend apart ripping into him
like a buttery soft steak the zombies
then come for blonde hair girl just as
this purple hair girl captain of the
kendo club busts in and saves her just
as more zombies burst into the room
meanwhile in the science lab pink haired
girl and glasses guy try to find some
makeshift weapons to use finding a gas
instilled nail gun right in the nick of
time the zombies bust down the door but
not before glasses guy customizes the
crap out of his nail gun and shoots all
the zombies popping their heads with
some blue collar nails and the duo runs
off into the hallway back on the roof
takashi and rey use a fire hose and blow
all the zombies away now knowing that no
one is coming to save them and they
decide to head to takashi's house and
after that to meet up with any other
survivors in the hallway pink haired
girl makes the most shocking discovery
and notices that all the zombies are in
fact blind only relying on sound to hunt
for their prey this is their weakness
glasses guy begins taking out zombies
left and right just as one creeps up
behind pink-haired girl causing her to
fill the hallways with her terrified
screams this alerts the few nearby
survivors to her area and the friend
group increases by a few more zombie
killing students holy crap willy wonka
this is my golden ticket this is
priceless information by noticing that
they rely on sound to find their prey is
enormous this changes everything and
rather than focusing on killing them
however i can i would begin focusing on
collecting small throwable items that we
could have used against the zombies
because in theory if zombies are blind
and only rely on sounds then that means
we could have simply distracted most of
them using non-important throwable items
which would make a lot of sound erupt on
one side of the room while we run
towards the other side to safety they
already have makeshift weaponry and
finally before we get out of this school
we're going to try to stop at the
cafeteria if we can assuming that the
place is not overrun because there is
probably still food and even more
weapons that we can stock up on there
once that is done i would use our loud
throwable items to distract the zombies
away from the courtyard allowing us
clear access and escape the school
entirely the group decides to divide and
conquer splitting up to kill the
horrifying brain eaters left and right
killing every single one of them as the
gang familiarizes themselves with each
other and take refuge in the classroom
for the time being to assess the
situation more thoroughly and to listen
in on the world news they hear on the
news that this plague has taken over the
whole world by storm meaning nowhere is
safe for anybody the news advises
everyone to stay inside but the group
suspects that the news is covering up
the real severity of the situation not
wanting the world to panic the news also
says that tactical warheads will be
deployed to help combat the situation
the group then decides that the first
order of business is to find out if
their families are okay then secure a
new home to hold up for a while teaming
up and using all of their combined
skills the group heads out of the front
door and take out zombie after zombie
taking brains and taking names the gang
finally reaches the courtyard and they
come across some more survivors deciding
to save them as well and offering them a
ride next up the bus at the ground floor
the group stops and reassesses it's
chaos out there with zombies everywhere
meaning the only way they'll get through
is by going through quietly with gliding
feet and light steps takashi creeps
around all the zombies until one of his
friends messes up badly that's it the
zombies know where they are the group
needs to run doing absolutely everything
that they can the group finally makes it
to the bus but not before they lose a
member becoming this school's next
japanese human sushi snack
okay this gang is stupid the main kids
seem to have their [ __ ] together but not
everyone else does and of course why
would they they're all kids what takashi
should have done was to have ordered
smaller groups made up of two or three
people to head towards the bus taking
turns to head to the bus in an orderly
fashion people in smaller groups could
have paid better attention to their
partners and could have helped guide the
ones who were more likely to mess up
having better control in a smaller group
rather than a bigger one yes the process
would have been slower but taking a more
methodical approach would have been the
smarter thing to do remember this whole
group is made of a bunch of kids and we
know how kids can be takashi and crew
reach the bus but the intensity isn't
over in the distance they see another
group of students led by a teacher and
the gang decides whether or not they
should wait for them but this isn't no
ordinary group and the teacher is more
sinister than he looks leaving behind a
desperate classmate to die to save
himself takashi's group has yet to
realize that this man will cause them
more horrifying troubles in the future
barely making it everybody finally gets
on as the bus takes off and charges
right out of the front gate of the
school but the menacing realities of the
world aren't over for them just yet
because this teacher is more of a freak
than his haircut makes him look as he
tries to convince everyone on the bus to
make him the leader of the group and in
the back of the bus the class students
begin to eat right out of his hand
alerting the core group to the dangers
of this man and for what's to come okay
while i admit this creepo teacher is
definitely giving off some strange vibes
and the fact that he wants to be the
leader so badly for seemingly no
apparent reason is majorly suspicious
from the looks of things he's a showman
and also a smooth talker and has a
psychopathic vibe due to his charm and
manipulative nature he's already
infiltrated himself as the man for the
job within these gullible teenagers
especially the ones in the back which is
a major problem as society is on the
brink of collapse meaning social order
is one hair away from chaos and that
means societal rules aren't as important
which means we either need to stop him
now or leave this group behind because
the power that he has when society is
done for will be similar to that of a
cult leader meaning whatever he says
goes and his followers due to their
devotion to him will do whatever he says
at any cost i would calmly tell this
teacher to postpone the selection of a
leader for now until we figure out our
next move or most importantly have the
opportunity to leave this bus for good
or kill him this would likely make him a
bonafide martyr at this point meaning
that his students would likely want
payback and would come in the form of
sabotage or backstabbing at some point
in the future which we can't afford to
have right now and we can't have a
democracy vote as his group has seven
people while our group has six which
means the teacher's class would outvote
us in this instance so our only option
is to either postpone the selection of
the leader in some way or kill the
teacher i would prefer killing him but
that would mean killing the rest of the
students which would not be a great plan
the creepy teacher's antics piss off rey
who storms off the bus just as takashi
tries to get her to come back on board
but suddenly a massive raging bust comes
hurtling towards them at full speed full
of undead monsters crashing right in
front of takashi and rey causing them to
barely get out of there with their lives
but the tunnel becomes blocked off so
takashi says to meet up with them at the
east police station nearby takashi and
rey run off barely making it out yet
again after a while takashi manages to
steal a bike while they drive off to the
police station driving now through the
new wasteland that is tokyo city with no
one living or dead to greet them on
their travels even managing to find a
gun for safe keeping i would prefer to
add a silencer to that just saying but
unfortunately their luck finally takes a
turn and they run low on gas forcing
them to hit up the next gas station they
see takashi andrei end up not having any
available cash nor credit cards to pay
for the gas so takashi heads inside the
store to get some just then he hears the
horrifying screams coming from rey right
outside forcing takashi to run back out
to take a look and he has rey by the
throat the gangster forces takashi to
throw his bat away drawing the nearing
hordes of zombies with the sound that
comes with it and this gangster makes
him fill up the vike with gas takashi
has had enough and at the last moment
whips out his gun and shoots this guy
conomy sudo style saving rey like the
stud that he is and getting the hell out
of there leaving this loser to his
horrifying fate okay well i do
appreciate takashi's noble knight in
shining armor nature he did not need to
run back out of there as soon as he
heard her scream takashi knows rey well
enough that she would not just scream
for no reason so he did not need to run
out of there and expose himself like
that rushing out of there put him at a
disadvantage the better option would
have been to go with the element of
surprise which would have been way more
efficient and way more quiet takashi
already has a gun meaning he wouldn't
need to close the distance as much as he
would have needed with an edged weapon
and if we remember the bike needed gas
to drive but the gas tank needed cash
first to allow this meaning takashi
could have stayed hidden within the
store until the gangster entered the
store himself once the gangster entered
the store takashi could have simply
waited for his chance and put some lead
right into his brain there was no need
to rush and expose himself to the
gangster worst case rey would have died
and we still would have gone out
scot-free with a dead gangster on our
hands now driving across the city
takashi and rey witnessed the entire
city going to hell with living breathing
people and zombies alike trying to kill
everyone no one is safe they stop near a
bridge out of town but it's packed so
they decide to head to unbetsu bridge
another route out of town where they
hope to meet up with the gang back on
the bus the gang sits in traffic as the
only exits out of the city are packed
with terrified frightened people hoping
to leave tokyo city before it's too late
glasses guy talks with pink-haired girl
as they discuss where to go mentioning
that they need to cross unpets bridge
and head to the police station but
they're running out of time as this
teacher is clearly warping his students
minds turning half of the group into a
cult so the main gang leaves the bus in
search of another vehicle but on the
bridge the situation isn't any better
the gang comes face to face with
terrifying hordes of zombies encircling
the group and trapping them back on the
bike however takashi and ray drive near
the bridge and see a truck and takashi
uses this moment to pull off and can i
say a freaking stud move blasting up the
ramp and launching into the sky landing
right in front of the group and managing
to take out a few zombies in the process
helping the gang kick zombie butt but
crossing this bridge isn't that easy and
crossing through the stream isn't an
option so blonde haired girl offers her
friend's apartment to them and that she
has a key to it nearby saying that the
gang can go there and take refuge for a
bit okay this blonde girl is more silly
than she looks and that's me being nice
this is the type of stuff that maybe you
should have brought up in conversation
way earlier i mean come on realistically
in the event of a zombie apocalypse
holding up is probably our best option
in the intermediate term a zombie
apocalypse would last for far less than
you think after all zombies are
practically walking corpses which means
in theory the longer we stay holed up in
our houses the progressively weaker and
weaker all of these zombies become which
then would become even easier for us to
kill over the coming days the zombies
that wouldn't be killed by wild animals
would eventually succumb to weather
exposure as a zombie has no instinct to
seek shelter they'll either freeze or
dry out over the coming days the
smartest thing that we can do right now
is to wait indoors now of course this is
highly dependent on the type of shelter
we're heading to the gang relaxes in the
apartment as the news claims that the
situation is only getting worse with the
virus now claiming over 2 million
victims with projected amounts to go
over 10 million victims within 2 days
meaning 10 million more zombies to deal
with the gang needs to prepare for
what's to come but luckily blonde girl's
friend's place is packing more than just
luxury square footage back on the bridge
the cops say that they've lost almost
all contacts from upper management
saying their last order was to do
whatever it takes to hold and claim this
bridge from the masses trying to get
through even killing someone and
shooting them in the head they mean
business and no one is getting through
near the apartment the gang spots a
father and daughter as they go house to
house begging to be let in and saved
from the horrifying hordes that are
enclosing in on them but this isn't a
civil world anymore and nobody trusts
anybody the dad then bangs and bangs on
one door but suddenly gets stabbed
leaving his daughter alone to face the
horrors that will soon reach her but
glasses guy has got her in his sights
and fires off round after round picking
off the flesh eating zombies left and
right alerting everybody in the
apartment the horde outside and even
this random dog which totally throws out
their plan to stay hidden and to not
make a sound they have a new mission
rescue that little girl takashi heads
off on the bike to save her with glasses
guy covering him from the rooftop
takashi dashes through the zombies and
crashes hard right in front of her he
quickly kills off the surrounding
zombies picks this girl up and heads for
the top of the wall holy crap this is
actually terrifying these zombies just
came out of nowhere and now our nice
little spot is compromised now i'm not
one for showing any acts of decency
because this is the apocalypse people
but alright let's talk about this
situation for a sec one he should have
brought more than his revolver and two
he should have brought a piece of string
and a coin but otherwise takashi for one
has got a huge set of marbles on him
because he went in hard and from the
looks of things he managed to secure the
gate entrance which was smart on his end
but he took a risk in walking in between
the wall when he was carrying that girl
the zombies could have easily grabbed
onto his foot and made him fall which is
why i think we should have been a little
more sneaky again the zombies have poor
to no eyesight relying mainly on sound
he could have used his bike and have
fastened two pieces of strength along
with the coin that we brought and would
have tied it to the horn button on the
motorbike this would have allowed the
bike to sound off with its horn luring
the zombies away by the noise and
covering any sound that we make as we
scaled over the wall with the kid and
climbed in between house to house slowly
making her way back to our safe house
takashi balances his life and this
girl's life on the thin edge wall as
they try to walk back to the apartment
but the gang waits for no one and dash
into the hummer with all of their things
and rushed to go save takashi the girl
and the dog driving off to avoid the now
millions of hordes of zombies alerted to
their apartment location elsewhere up in
the sky even the united states president
and his cabinet have subcumbed to the
virus with almost all of air force one
now turned undead the president has a
choice to make before he dies to enter
the code to launch an attack on the
world before they use intercontinental
missiles to destroy the us activating
triple six delta protocol before
everyone dies back in japan the gang
finally crosses the river reaching the
other side but something isn't right
because there's no one around dead or
alive to be seen the gang cautiously
drives through the empty streets finding
not a single soul until a horde of
zombies comes up on the road being
present around every street their
numbers keeps growing larger and larger
as the gang gets into the city forcing
the group to drive right through them
killing hundreds of them in seconds but
they suddenly notice a wired fence cut
right through the road forcing the gang
to make a quick turn and drift near it
almost running into a wall in the
process and causing rey to injure
herself they are now trapped with
hundreds of zombies closing on them
takashi jumps down to save rey and
starts blasting away the zombies left
and right but there are way too many for
him to control so purple-haired girl
jumps down to help him out killing as
many undead as she can but they're
running out of time and they've got to
figure out a better way to handle this
before they die this group could have
gotten out from the get-go it's obvious
that the wired fence is holding off the
zombies the gang could have jumped over
the wired fence and ran away or if they
couldn't for whatever reason another
method could have been resolved by
taking advantage of their inability to
see and rely on sound the gang could
have stayed in the hummer with takashi
and someone else to begin making noise
on the opposite end of the road luring
the zombies away from the hummer and
they would have been blinded to what was
actually going on for the majority
staying in the hummer would have only
given them temporary protection against
the zombies and would have muffled any
sounds that the gang could have given
off thereby giving the zombies a chance
to hone in on only one source of sound
being drawn in from that area by making
sure that takashi and whoever else is
with them make the loudest noise
possible to lure the zombies away
staying in the hummer would have also
shielded the gang from giving off their
scent which at this moment is a
preventative measure since we don't know
for sure if the zombies can smell since
up until now this hasn't been
established yet but i personally am not
going to take that chance the gang runs
nearly out of bullets forcing everyone
to take some drastic raunchy measures
purple-haired girl and takshi try to
lure the zombies away from the hummer by
running up the nearby stairs but there's
too many of them and they don't budge
forcing the gang to use up the rest of
their ammo and they know that their
minutes are numbered but that's just
when the most insane thing happens some
folks dressed in firefighter gear show
up across the fence and blast the close
by zombies with pressurized water
cannons and one of them turns out to be
pink-haired girl's mother takashi and
purple-haired girl make a run for it and
they plan to meet back with the group at
a later point since takashi knows where
pink hair girl lives takashi and
purple-haired girls stumble across a
bike shop as they run through the empty
streets and they decide to go with an
amphibious vehicle and the duo launches
into the river nearby they decide to
stay at a nearby temple right by pink
haired girl's house for the night
because they know they won't make it to
the house in time because no one should
stay out at night not anymore takashi
and purple-haired girl make it to the
temple and rest up for the night the
next day arrives as silence fills the
empty stone streets takashi opens the
temple door not knowing what terrors
await him until an entire horde of
zombies climbs up the steps and heads
straight for him and purple hair girl
somehow they knew their location despite
them not making a single sound the
entire night or
did they
they are in trouble for starters he
should have secured that temple better
and have looked for a back exit the
second he got there and also while the
zombies can't see properly there is
still an issue of smell which we haven't
taken into account we don't know for
sure but it's reasonable to assume that
the zombies were led there by our scent
aside from simply going through them i
would have put our very own samurai
purple haired girl on for protection
duty to guard us and i would have gutted
a single zombie before placing their
organs at intestines all over us this
would have allowed us to see if by
dressing up as a zombie with the scent
would make the zombies leave us alone
and if this doesn't work we could have
simply lured enough of them around the
walkway of the temple this way the
zombies could have been led around the
temple which would have cleared the
pathway enough for us to get out of
there the duo does their best to break
through this zombie horde and run for
their lives finally reaching pink-haired
girl's mother's house a sprawling
compound filled with other workers and
security for everybody including for
pink-haired girl's dad a hard-aged man
who is known as the big boss of the area
and for a brief moment the gang almost
feels as if things have gone back to
normal but nothing is built to last and
the adults in the compound treat the
kids like [ __ ] and boss them around
treating them like kids who have not
gone through a zombie apocalypse knowing
that this type of structure won't work
for long the kids get together and
decide if they should get absorbed by
the now large compound group or should
strike out on their own but the outside
is only getting worse with millions of
zombies coming to life every day but
pink-haired girl knowing her terrible
family thinks that they won't last long
in here back on the teacher's bus
however the gang after all this while
has gone absolutely nuts brainwashing
all of these teenagers for the worst and
turning this group into an official mad
men cult and they also finally find the
same compound that takashi's group is in
but takashi's got some other problems in
the compound the group realized that
everyone here is too close-minded and
everyone here doesn't think that the
undead zombies are really zombies they
think that everything is fine in the
outside world when in reality it's the
complete opposite the compound somehow
thinks that takashi and his group are
just stupid children carrying weapons
and drunk on power and it's only a
matter of time until they get that power
taken away from them alright i hate to
be the one to break it to you kids but
uh you're all just kids if i'm a 17 year
old with self image problems and pent up
hormones i would stop for a moment to
think about the reality of our situation
one barely a few days has passed and
we've been really really lucky in this
situation the longer we stay out in the
open the higher risk we have of getting
injured and or killed or turned into a
zombie and zombies aren't going to be
our only enemy there are thousands of
anarchists criminals people who despise
the current lawful status quo and won't
hesitate to take advantage of the fall
of society they won't hesitate to kill
innocent people and do whatever they
want it's only a matter of time to one
of us gets killed out there and as
society falls the decomposing zombies
will be the least of our problem
realistically i would bite the bullet
and take all the [ __ ] this porta-potty
dump of a safe haven would give us as in
i would stay here where it's safe and
not leave this place probably as long as
i can takashi then goes to pink hair
girl's dad and says that rey's dad is a
cop so he can find out what's going on
if he heads to the nearby police station
and as well as find her mother in the
process too but pink haired girl's dad
says that in less than two days the
entire compound will leave this area
that the city is far too dangerous to
stay in for much longer but takashi says
that he'll be back before they go and if
he doesn't well then that probably means
that something happened to him later as
he prepares to leave purple-haired girl
offers to keep him company with her
charms and her sword and just then they
meet a familiar face their old teacher
but rey isn't having any of his [ __ ] and
sticks him up at gunpoint and forcing
him and his crazy cult to leave the
compound before something happens to him
the blonde haired girl also finally
manages to remember her friend's phone
number the friend whose apartment they
stayed at earlier she picks up and
reunites with blond-haired girl for a
brief second on the phone however
elsewhere hidden in the depths of the
ocean a submarine gets word of the
executive order given by air force one
and the submarine launches a trident
warhead into the sky the warhead blasts
right over tokyo and cuts blond-haired
girls phone line along with all other
electronics over the area cutting off
everyone from everything and at the same
time this explosion cuts off the
electronic breaks of the schoolteacher's
bus causing him to crash right into the
wall of the compound unleashing the dead
and killing everyone holy [ __ ] this is
insane everything and everyone just got
hit with what looks like an emp blast
which is an electromagnetic pulse that
can temporarily or permanently damage
electronics by generating high voltage
in high current surges despite
conventional wisdom according to life
wire it is unlikely that the majority of
cars even today would suffer any
long-term permanent damage although at
this rate we don't have time to sit and
wait around and people are panicking
which means we could have used this
situation to take advantage of everyone
we don't have enough bullets to kill
every single zombie but we do have some
bait tons and tons of bait i'd say
excuse me thank you ma'am and lob some
grenades over the resting crowds nearby
killing everyone oops but by doing this
i would use their varied bloody body
parts as a meaty distraction to lure the
zombies in while i slip away out the
back but not before heading into the
estate kitchen inside i'm going to grab
more supplies more food and more knives
and i'm gonna leave this hell hole
forever hundreds of people start to
panic as the compounds people and the
kids barely managed to hold it together
slicing off zombie heads and limbs like
it's butter but everyone knows that this
won't last long as thousands more undead
swarmed the compound so pink-haired
girl's dad orders everyone to take his
copper-plated anti-emp vehicle with him
opting to stay behind with his people
and his wife to hold back the undead
long enough for the high school group of
teenagers to get out of there and head
off into the distance living yet another
day in this new world filled with the
undead and if you want to live another
day in the zombie wasteland don't forget
to like subscribe comment and check out
our how to be playlist down below peace